um
so um we'll skip this panel so this is
me uh i'm alq on twitter so if you have
anything
any comments questions please let me
know also if you have any comments or
questions during the talk uh
fire away um because you know i i want
to
i want to have it as interactive as
possible
um so what i figured we'd talk about
tonight um there's a few things so first
of all and that's not going to be
product you know not a product pitch but
just explain what the problem space is
what it is that we're dealing with so
what we do and who
who is the user of datadog then from
there we'll go into
a little bit of domain constraints so
with based on what the problem space is
what constraints it entails
and what constrains uh it doesn't tell
us what kind of trade-offs you can make
then we look at the data model not
obviously the you know
the actual objects we're using or the
data structures we use but
more the way we can represent the
problem access patterns which
basically is how do we access the data
or how our users access the data
which then will get to a presentation of
our architecture which is
by and large a really iterative um
architecture so it you know took us a
few years to get there
um not designed to be you know
authorities or anything like that
um also look at the tools that we use
data stores languages libraries and so
on and so forth
and um last um a few challenges that um
that that we faced so we'll kind of you
know just discuss a few
uh technical challenges that is okay
so what data dog is is uh it's
infrastructure monitoring as a service
so it's a monitoring tool
and i'm so who who here uses a
monitoring tool you know as an
infrastructure monitoring tool
okay so maybe a third a third of a third
of the audience
um so it's something that watches
performance metrics coming from that
kind of
you know that kind of uh tools so
anything from
uh databases web web front ends load
balancers
web uh so web tiers application servers
um it's even uh bare metal you know aws
or um and so on and so forth so the idea
is that you have one place
um because your application is typically
built on top of
a bunch of these components you have one
place where you can see how the app is
is performing
um so so far so good all right
now um so what is really monitoring as a
highest level what uh
what does it mean so really it's um so
it's a tool it's a system
it's whatever you've installed whatever
wakes wakes you up at night when
something goes wrong but really
um it's the primary interface you have
to understand
your application so if you're running an
app um whether it's
if it's non-trivial um if it's just
distributed application you'll end up
um having something that tells you how
well it's doing where it's failing the
bottlenecks and so on and that's your
monitoring system
so it's really it's the primary
interface we can learn and understand
how your system is doing um you can
i mean if you go if you say if you have
a data center you can't just go walk in
the data center look at the racks
and kind of understand what's happening
obviously
so so you need something to sort of to
mediate that and that is
in essence your monitoring system now in
the worst cases your monitoring system
is your customers because basically they
they tell you when something goes wrong
and you know you fix it that's not
the i mean it's one way to do it it's
not the way i'd recommend but um it's
been done in the past
um in the better case is you have
something that kind of
sucks performance metrics all the time
you know around the clock from your
various components from your software
and tells you hey this is going well
this is you know there's a problem here
but that's that's essentially what it is
um two uh quick um
quick taxonomy about metrics so the
monitoring system what it consumes first
and foremost is metrics it's
and metrics um so an example of a metric
is for instance
at the lowest level could be how much
cpu a particular machine
is um or how busy is a cpu in a given
machine
at the highest level it could be how
many users on the site
at a given time so it really it really
varies the taxonomy is relatively simple
though so you have in terms of metrics
that you're going to care about
it's either about resource or workload
so resource metrics is
stuff you consume so it could be you
know cpu network memory storage
and so on and workload is what you
produce what your application
what it is that you're running on the
box is producing or or
the application as a whole is producing
and really
um to understand how things are going
how your how your application your
system is performing
and that by the way applies to could be
a factory it could be anything you know
in the case of a factory you have um you
know you get stuff in
you produce widgets and workloads how
many widgets you produce an hour so
that's a physical work
in our world the software world um so
resources typically you know with the
machines
the resources the machine and workload
is you know whatever it is that you're
producing so
this taxonomy applies kind of regardless
of of the application
that you you've written or you use
and that's going to be you know that
that's
that that's one way to look at the
metrics and so the monitoring system
will
first and foremost consume these metrics
and make some judgment or
display display that will make some
judgment about um
you know whether they're they're good or
bad if you will
so far so good questions all right
um now concretely speaking um
now in the case i mean i took some
screenshots on it so that's that's the
product page part of the um of the
presentation um
what when you use the monitoring system
first and foremost you're basically
graphing a lot of stuff
um so this is one example and the idea
is that
you can you're not graphing because you
like colors and you like stuff that
moves and you know it's cool
you're graphing because really quickly
with you know you can see
interesting patterns you know here and
there there are different metrics but
they exhibit the same pattern
um whether it's kind of flat whether
this is getting bad here or so
whether there's a spike here so the
brain is amazingly good at
figuring out patterns and that's why a
lot of the monitoring tools now
offer including datadog a really rich
graphing library so the idea is that
let's walk through an example of
monitoring so you have
there are i have here two metrics one of
throughput and one of contention
um so it could be you know anything
could be number of pages served or
whatever number of people walk in the
subway um at a given station
and contention is in so the measure of
how many unique things are you know in
contention are consumed
and so the the typical you know the way
you can use a monitoring system is
so you have these two metrics there's
you have an intuition or you from
experience you understand that there's
some kind of relationship between both
and what you want to be able to do is
you want to be able to with your
merchant system
so formulate a hypothesis with a few key
strokes
transform the data a little bit so that
you can identify patterns
much much faster and so in this case if
you take the derivative of both
metrics i mean in this case if you if
you sum everything take the derivative
and you
inherit the derivative the first first
derivative you can see that there's some
kind of correlation between
uh between contention and throughput
which um
you know by the way you could kind of
figure out if you have you know if you
have contention
on something um for instance turn styles
in subway station
um you're the number of people entering
the subway station is gonna
it's gonna get uh it's gonna decrease so
that's that's a quick
that's a quick example of using a
monitoring system
now so it's really about getting a quick
feedback loop being able to understand
what your application is doing and be
able to
play with the data slice and dice to
transform in a way that you
quickly you can quickly validate
hypothesis
does that make sense i see people around
yeah go ahead
so i mean this is this is um
uh the this in particular is the number
of locks in a
relational database so and and that it
could be anything but in this case
that's what it is and that
that application the throughput of that
application depends on
that relational database and so whenever
it starts to lock up
um everybody in that in that application
starts to wait for
our you know for their turn to grab the
lock or the locks
you know as it were cool
all right so the second thing so you do
graphing and
you know you manipulate the data the
second thing you want to do with the
monitoring system
is you do a lot of alerting and alerting
is really automatic detection because
you don't have time to watch a thousand
metrics
um so that's you know defined alerts
threshold i mean you can do a number of
different things but that's
that's the other thing um another very
common use case
of of monitoring
and the third use case is more of a what
i call team sport
is that whenever you have a complex
application you need to be able to
talk about the data you know you just
you have a lot of back and forth so this
is
for instance one discussion we had on
the facebook metric that's kind of
actually talking about this improvement
uh so that's really the three main use
cases of a monitoring system
um it's uh so you do a lot of graphing
it's real time of course i mean hence
the
hence the title of the talk um it is you
so you graph you do a lot of graphing
you alert you want to learn from the
metrics and then you do a lot of
collaboration around the data to try to
understand
really understand what the application
is doing because if you just look at the
architecture diagram you don't really
understand much
that's the sad truth so um
knowing that what are no that's a
problem in space that's how that's the
use cases if you will so the highest
level of the description of the problem
so what kind of constraints does that
does that entail and the idea again is
that
we start from um kind of the highest
level um
use cases and we look at the constraints
and then it tells us what kind of
trade-offs we can do
and then that's going to help us find
you get to some architecture
so uh domain constraints the first one
is the is latency
so when i'm in real time there's a lot
of understanding of real time
i mean real time in the sense that this
is a 10 to 30 second latency between the
time
you collect a given metric for instance
how much cpu a machine is using
to the time you can you can see it on on
a graph
so it's it's 10 to 30 sec it's typically
within 10 or 30 seconds there's a number
of factors it could be one second or
half a second
there's a number of factor um that play
there could be time it takes to send the
data and time takes to process it and so
on so forth
um the interesting thing is that so it's
really time to signal so
time from the moment you collect there's
a program somewhere that collects
um the metric to the time you receive it
and your brain can do something with it
um it's not really page load so the page
the page is you know
a little bit faster than that hopefully
but that's one key thing
so the idea is that if you so it's not
200 milliseconds
it's not one microsecond and because for
this particular domain
um you're not going to be able to react
to there's a cpu spike of a microsecond
because
what are you going to do there's no
there's nothing actionable there
it's also not 10 minutes in the sense
that you don't want to
you know find out you don't want your
customers to call you and say hey
the website is slow and because they in
10 minutes they can figure out that
there's a problem
so that's where 10 to 30 seconds kind of
maps to how fast somebody
and people can look at the graph
rock it and then react on it
so that's first first constraint um
second constraint is it's availability i
mean that's kind of uh
standard but in this case we get data uh
when you run a monitoring service you
get data 24 7 365 blah blah
there's no um there's no seasonality
because it's just machines talking to
the machine so
you know it's thanksgiving it'll be as
busy as um
you know tomorrow it doesn't really
matter it just increases ever so slowly
as we have more uses
more machines reporting to the system
and the third key constraint is that you
want to have access control and that's
very generic to any multi-tenanted
system so if you run something as a
service usually you'll have all your
data in one place but you have multiple
users that don't necessarily want to see
each other's data so
in our case that means obviously that
you know the data that we receive
has to be partitioned by account
so um now let's look at degrees of
freedom and i'll try to make it
you know as the talk advances it gets
more and more concrete
um so fair enough so degrees of freedom
what kind of trade-offs you can make
um so uh i talked a little bit about the
100 millisecond round trip
i don't care if i if it takes 100 you
know 50 milliseconds between the time
i gather metric on a machine at the time
i can see it because
if it takes two seconds it'll be the
same result um you know
that's there's not a time so there's no
point in over engineering to get like
super fast latency so this is not a
financial trading application this is
really
monitoring um monitoring infrastructure
so that's
um we can get away with that the second
thing is we don't have to
engineer for crazy elasticity you know
certain bursts black friday cyber monday
etc
etc that's not we don't really care um
in our case what really drives the
amount of volume data the volume of data
we get is how many customers or how many
users
connect their machines to data logs so
we can start streaming
streaming metrics to us the third one we
can get away with to some extent is
precision and that's an interesting one
so precision um kind of acts as a
counterbalance or not a counterbalance
but
can be antagonistic with latency so here
you have two
essentially the same metric um in two
different configurations
one where it's very precise that is to
say you have a lot of data points and so
you can see it's kind of more jagged
the problem is it's late so i mean the
the the x axis which is time doesn't
really matter what it is but you know
the actual scale but it's not very
useful because here you'd have to basic
decision something that happened
maybe an hour ago ten minutes ago it's
much more useful to have something
that's less precise but has
lower latency and that's kind of a key
thing i mean that's that's
speaking related to the real-time aspect
of the
um of the of the architecture and of the
talk is that
i'd much rather have this than that i
don't care for a high level precision
um and so that's an interesting
trade-off because that means that
if you're as as you're processing data
as you're receiving data you're graphing
it
if your processing systems start to slow
down if you if your pipeline starts to
slow down
you can say all right i'll skip a bunch
of points um to just catch up because i
don't care
of having every single point there i'd
rather make sure that i can catch up and
be uh be up to date so that's kind of an
interesting
trade-off that of course will not work
at all in a financial application where
you want to count every single you know
money transfer for instance so you
cannot
in our case we can skip points we can
skip data points
you know so and i guess i'm grateful for
that but
um that doesn't necessarily apply to
what you guys are doing
so um just having everything in one page
uh constraints
so latency 10 to 30 seconds roughly
always available
um highly access controlled data the
freedoms we have at least some of the
degrees of freedom we have is i don't
care about 100 millisecond
round trip less than 100 millisecond
round trip or even less than a second
really
um we haven't i don't care about
elasticity it's a very predictable
pattern of data we ingest
and i i care about precision but um
that's one thing i can
give away if it in exchange for latency
i can trade
i can trade precision good
am i making sense okay cool
uh yeah do do tell me if if it's not
um if i'm not making sense so um
having said that i want to take a quick
look at um
what the monitoring data what it looks
like really from uh
you know maybe even more concretely so
there are two types of events um two i'm
sorry two types of
um data in monitoring really
so you have metrics and events um and so
metrics
are really basically time series so it's
the
metric could be the temperature of this
room um you know
hour after hour it's usually anything it
could be
number of bytes processed by an
interface inside a machine it could be
number of visitors to your side it can
be
um can be pretty much anything um
anything that's a that's a time series
so
um and events are just annotation i'll
show you a little bit more detail so
metrics time series so at the most basic
level is basically it's time stamps and
values that's
that's the basic representation has has
a bunch of metadata it could be the name
of the metrics for instance
number of people in the audience um has
some context which is
meetup data engineering meetup you know
the date is xyz
has some units if this is the number of
people for instance
has an owner in this case who's
measuring uh to whom the data belongs to
etc
that's pretty much it i mean in rc7
datadog that's kind of the core data
um that's the core data model if you
will so it's very very simple
it's very very uniform um there's not a
ton of variations
the resolution we chose is that of a
second and that's really again back to
what i was saying um in terms of it
takes
you know at least you know 10-30 seconds
to interpret a graph to be able to be
able to react to it
to to understand what the data is
telling you so there's no point in
measuring things
um at a resolution lower than 100 then
for one second and it's adequate to
capture those
signals um of less than 0.5 hertz
and now when you think about it the way
so the way it really works if you set up
data dog you for instance deploy it on
your laptop you'll have a little
program little agent that's going to run
collect metrics about how what your cpu
is doing what your memory is doing
which program are running and so on and
so forth that
typically is going to sample data every
10 to 20 seconds
it could sample more often but you don't
want to you don't want to waste
cycles to measure you also want your
laptop or your server to do interesting
things
um useful things so that's why even
though we can measure
things down to a second typically if you
look at
at graphs we're giving you there you'll
have a point every 10 to 20 seconds
if you have and this is maybe slightly
i would say off topic but in case you
want to measure higher frequency signals
you can use something called statsd
which will pre-aggregate whatever
metrics you want to send it and we'll
consume that
so overall metrics the interesting thing
there are two interesting things
one they're pretty high signal noise
ratio
in the sense that if you have a very
noisy metric something that goes all
over the place it's probably not very
useful
um in the first place so you need to
derive it to get something useful
so it also speaks to the fact that you
can lose some precision
and still kind of be able to understand
um
you know what the metric is telling you
what the performance of the system for
instance
is and the second thing which is great
it's is that metrics are immutable
so because there's a time stamp and
nobody's figured out time travel yet
will be able to you to persist metrics
and then they're never going to change
because they measure something that
happened in the past essentially
um so quick example um if you want to
measure so io 8 is the
i use in this case resource metrics so
what
what the machine is doing what the cpu
is doing um this is number of cycles
in percentage that are spent waiting on
on some kind of disk for instance
um so we have this is the example of a
query
um so now the result if you if you send
this query into data.
because use case number one graphing
um we're mostly interested in displaying
data there's no point
um in giving you a million data points
back if we're going to
compress that to a graph that's going to
fit in your screen so it's typically you
know 200 to 600 points for display
um and these points are essentially
times that value times the value times
the value
and when you graph them this is what you
get you know you can i mean this is
something that's
this is actually i think a measure on on
a machine so that's something i took um
i think this morning
so the interesting thing because
graphing is one of our main use cases
the resolution isn't um
the resolution is time independent by
that i mean if you look at one hour data
you get say 600 points if you look at
one month of data you also get 600
points so there's clearly some time
there's a time aggregation that takes
place so that
we don't the system doesn't query if you
look at a month of data and you have two
million points
we don't query two million points sent
back to the browser two million points
and
wait for the browser to render two
million points of course we we
act we time aggregate as we query and
return to you
just 200 to 600 points so you have a
nice graph
does that make sense
um so if you want to get a little bit
more complex and i want to
uh explain a little bit also um kind of
some of the intricacies of uh of
time series and monitoring let's say you
want the same metric but average
across the number of machines a number
of sources if you will so
the query is slightly different i don't
it's not that important
the results are always the same 200 to
600 points because again this is for
graphing and
you don't really care about um about
having a million data points to only
graph 400
at the end the the interesting thing is
that in this case you get the average
across a number of machines so what
we do what we call spatial aggregations
so you basically
take this which is um the metric for all
the machines and you compute the average
so because at the end this is what
you're asking the system to produce
um and so one interesting thing is that
because
not all data is sampled at the same time
you have to do
some form of interpolation so that you
can you can
basically um compute the average on
uh on the same on the same timestamps
does that make sense that part okay cool
if it doesn't you know please raise your
hand so um so this
this time aggregation this space
aggregation
um happening so that's these are
examples of metrics and the kind of
processing we do on them and the kind of
queries you can do often
events are really so this is much more
uh simple so the kind of stuff we
collect
is a really um time-based textual
annotation so it could be oh i released
a new version of the software or oh
somebody got a page because
um a web a web machine went down or
um anything oh we started a new you know
marketing campaign
and so on so forth so the data model is
very simple it has title body and then
some metadata author attacks
as an example this is so here these are
events um
so nagios is a is a sort of
legacy monitoring system um we're
collecting just
so this is the metadata is what is what
it is
there's a title there's a body and
timestamp of course
and then that's it it's interesting to
you to mix events and metrics because it
lets you mark it lets you annotate the
data
because a lot of times for instance you
um
let's say you start a new marketing
campaign and so if you don't know that
and you see a huge spike in your web
traffic you like
shoot you know maybe the cdn is messed
up and
um we get all the traffic back to origin
server and we're going to just
die you know everything is going to burn
burn down to to the ground um but maybe
it's actually because
uh we you know there's a new really
successful marketing campaign
that's just driving more traffic and
just the reaction obviously you know
it's you you'll be careful in both cases
but in in the second case where you know
you can you know oh this is because
there's that or
it's probably because there's this new
marking campaign
being able to um sort of mix and match
it's really not very visible but there
are markers where i have the
the origin of the the arrows there
markers um
it's really useful because now you have
a sense of um
oh it's a brand new event i have no idea
this we're sort of in twilight zone i
don't know what's going on or
yes okay this is expected and then this
is what how we can react so it really
makes a huge difference
um from a you know from how you how you
react to it how you react to your
metrics
um so that's it i mean that's the core
data model in our in our
um in our architecture in the prominent
spaces that
and the rest is just um it's not extra
but it's not
not that important okay so now we know
what kind of data we produce
or gets materialized in the system let's
look at the way they're accessed
um how how how data flow so
um in most cases i mean this is a
the simplified workflow you have things
so agents being small machines
small programs on a machine collecting
metrics sending them through data
or um just um so
programs hitting our api just send data
so it gets into something that we'll
call intake gets queued gets processed
get persisted and then that data is
accessed
basically either because you're looking
at a graph via a browser
and that graph may be the last hour of
data for instance which is very common
is you want to know what's happening now
and once in a while you'll go back and
say oh let me look at what happened
a week ago or last month or something
like that
but the vast majority of the traffic
outbound so inbound is all the telemetry
all the metrics coming from the
servers and the applications outbound is
it's a little bit of recent data and
then very
frequently kind of the more random
queries
so on the intake what that means is that
um first of all we want to be able to
ingest data at a ever increasing
rate and that means i mean if the
business is successful we'll have more
customers customers have machines more
and more machines
that are sending more and more metrics
and applications that are certainly more
metrics so um the intake has to be able
to take more and more data basically
um and it's uh the kind of
there's no um
partition by time by that i mean all the
customers send all data
all the time there's no oh today's
tuesday i don't know it's customer a
it's going to send data so it's not
batch it's always like constant flow of
stuff coming in
the latency constraint that i mentioned
about so actually so
here i have 30 60 seconds more attention
30 seconds so that's again
between the time the data is collected
to the time it flows into the intake
it's gonna be
in the order of you know tens of seconds
not minutes not milliseconds
um and so when you have this kind of
stuff particularly when you have
um you're ingesting data you know at a
very constant rate
and you have a sort of fairly
sort of constant upper bound for latency
you end up basically having just a bunch
of queues that's
that's what i'll show um in a little bit
um outband queries it's obviously it's
query so it's different so you
inbound we send data outbound we get
basically graphs for instance so the
latency there is more like a few seconds
you start you say show me the graph and
you want to wait for a few seconds not
for
60 seconds for the graph to display the
time span that when you query the data
for
typically you want to look into most our
customers looking to the last
one to four hours because that's what i
want to know what my app is doing now
and
what it was doing six hours ago i mean
it's sometimes interesting but
most important is what's happening now
an interesting
thing is that and that's maybe a little
bit um
so i'll explain exactly the the queries
when you look at the parameters of the
queries so this time span there's a
metric you're interested in
the let's say the machine where it's
collected these are when you render
when you look at dashboards that people
put up of graphs
they tend to be slow moving dimensions
that is to say either you look at
a bunch of different metrics but it's
the same time span so it's um the time
is fixed basically you do a bunch of
queries but the time is fixed
or you look at um typically people may
look at
everything coming from a single machine
or one given metric across
a time machine so in that sense when you
do the query there's already some sort
of
locality of the of the parameters not
completely
completely random
and other kind of stuff that we have
outbound which i touched on
this is use case number two is alerts is
telling you when something goes wrong so
it's detecting anomalies
latency is typically 60 seconds because
you need
um you know there's no point in alerting
as soon as
a metric shoots up across uh above a
certain level
usually that's not what you want because
if you have a certain spike
you'll get a ton of false positives say
hey hey i'm above 100 hey i'm over 100
you don't want that you want
usually you want to know hey i'm above
100 and that's been the case for the
past five minutes or the past minute or
past
hour so depending on the on the case on
the use case but for instance
um i mean um let's say
uh i mean anything around like cpu for
instance is a good example
where you don't want to you know the
spike in cpu doesn't really matter
um you want to know you don't want to
know it you know
every second that something's happening
if it's for instance storage or some
kind of memory something that's
constrained where you don't have an
infinite amount of it
you want to know once you're getting
close to the limit because there's no
extending it
like you know if you run a for instance
this space you're not in this space
there's no
you want to know as soon as possible um
so um so that's alerts really and the
spatial aggregation if you
it makes things a little bit more
complex when you have a bunch of
different time series that
um that come at different point in time
and makes things a little bit
uh fuzzy especially towards sort of the
boundaries of the interval
and the last thing we want to send is
events so for instance
um when you query for events you say hey
give me the last the list of all
marketing launches for instance and you
again you want to wait for a few seconds
not for 10 minutes to get the results
so so that's inbound outbound in the
middle there's a bunch of stuff so
i it's it's all the stages i'll go over
them um
in a little bit basically things that
will for instance look at the incoming
metrics and
look for mlas um persist them uh do roll
ups to aggregations that you can
um you can have sort of constant you can
keep your latency fairly low
and do some kind of reporting so look at
data across the
across the board and producing reports
so the latencies again that we see in
the middle it varies between
if you want to resolve some something
right in you know in
in the flow um you want to for instance
resolve a metric name
from from some from a name to an actual
id identifiers to 10 milliseconds
if you want to query and assemble time
series um
a different resolution for instance if
you want if you say i want to see
a time series that's that spans a month
then it you should take about a second i
know more
and more detection i talked about it
typically 60 second latency
or 60 second time span or latency
no no less than that if you don't want
to do hourly aggregates so anything
any stage in the in the processing
pipeline that
rolls up hourly then obviously it's
every 60 minutes that it needs to wake
up and just do its stuff
um to compute the the aggregates for the
past hour
same thing for dailies and then if you
do bash reports every week and then it
takes um
you know it's like you run out of seven
days so the multiple latency the only
reason why i wanted to have have it
there is is to show kind of
the different time scale that that
exists throughout the system
and how and as you can imagine um
so something that's disk based 10
milliseconds probably not a good idea
um that's probably going to mean
something in memory so one second
that's probably something in memory as
well 60 seconds could be
could be memory it could be on disk
depending on the volume and so on so
forth
so that's why i had that interesting um
the interesting observation also that
again
is going to drive the architecture is
that the volume of data inbound volume
is
way way bigger than the volume of data
that's outbound
that's because you have i don't know
let's say
you know 100 000 machines telling
datadog hey
this is how i'm doing this is these are
my metrics and then you'll have
that 1000 people looking in front of
1000 screens so each one screen each
let's say
even two looking at 10 graphs so that's
you know only
20 000 queries at most whereas one
machine can generate 100 metrics so
there's a clear
symmetry between how much data we we're
ingesting and how much data we're
serving back
and that's that leads to some
interesting um sort of architectural
tweaks
good all right okay so now on to the
to so the architecture so a few design
constraints
or architectural constraints so inbound
because we have so much data coming in
compared to what we serve out we want to
have some you know durable queue
basically something that can
take the day that has a predictable
intake time so where you
want to write data persisted so it can
be processed later on
um it shouldn't take um you know you
should do
the time it takes to to get the data
should not
vary because otherwise you're backing up
at the very
entrance or the very um start of the
pipeline and that means your customers
are backing up as well so that means
they're not going to get the data on
time
and it's going to be scalable just
because i said that our sort of
intake volume is just ever so you know
grows and it's going to be scalable in
the sense that
um we want to spend less money if we
double the amount of
customers for instance we don't want to
double our bill
to ingest the data we want to have
something that's lower than that so
that's caliber in that sense
scalable also in the sense that it has
to consume a lot of data but that's
that's that
um outbound design constraints so for
outbound traffic you want to have fast
access to real-time data because
people want to see what's happening now
so um that's going to be the main use
case i want to see all my graphs
for what's happening now so you want to
have something that gives you fast
access
you also want to have fast access really
fast access to persistent data i.e
past data for instance where you want to
see oh um
i have you know 20
000 people on my site right now how much
did i have a week ago at the same time
you know same day just a week ago at the
same time
so that's prob that's gonna be that's
gonna live somewhere i mean if you have
a lot of memory it can be a memory but
at some point you're gonna have to
persist just do something that is not
memory
so you you need something that gives us
access to it um
and internally the kind of constraints
that we have is again uh
it's all cute it's a bunch of cues so
they've got to be pretty fast
we want to have minimal coupling between
the various uh aspects
if it's a pipeline that process your
data you don't want to have crazy
coupling because
if something happens somewhere you don't
want the problem too okay
too quickly and then we need a bunch of
data stores that
that ranges in durability and access
sort of inversely so you can have low
durability
database that is to say the data can go
fairly quickly and you may lose it but
very fast so that's typically you know
stuff in memory and then you lose the
box and then the memory is gone and then
that's it i mean you have to
find ways to fight that um all the way
to super high durability
that is to say um i don't care
but slower that is to say i don't care
um if it takes
you know a second to get the data but
that data has got to be there no matter
what so
because you know we are we we store
historical
um time series and that's kind of that's
we can't say
oops we lost the data sorry you know
we're um just come back later
okay so um from a so adding a little bit
a few pieces to the uh
to the equation so um really this is
what it looks like
you get data in um either from the
typically from through the api so or or
the machine descending to api hey this
is
how much shipping you're consuming for
instance um there's a bunch of
there's a lot of machines consumed so
acting as intake so ingesting the data
basically storing it
into either both in memory and then
chewing it
um on disk so the in memory
why you want to have it here is because
um if you
if somebody's asking for the data in
real time
you want to cut through you don't want
to read from disk what you just um
what you what you just wrote rather if
it's memory when you do a query you can
the web tier that's here can directly
hit the
storage and say hey you know i want the
i want the up to the second data
just give it to me and it's going to be
memory it's going to be just much faster
and because again it's a
it's a it's going to be a small fraction
the outbound traffic is going to be a
small fraction
in band traffic um you know you can you
can play it in a few games try to
optimize that
so otherwise the path is you go to cues
so stuff that gets queued up it gets um
and then
processed and then written to some
durable store and i'll explain which
which store we picked and then there's a
bunch of cataloging that happens as well
at the bottom so all that um which we
call data layer
is something that from the outside from
the web from the
web application looks like um something
you ask
give me this metric between time a and
time b
and it's going to return the time series
it does the magic for instance
if you're asking for data that spans the
last six hours
for us some of it will be served from
memory some some of it will be served
from the durable
um one of our data stroller cassandra in
this case um
and that's completely transparent so so
the delay the data layer
does exactly that it just mixes things
and makes them
uh seamless so it's an abstraction layer
i guess um
so that's really i mean the high level
architecture there's a there's not a
ton more um to it so data is really um
at the the core is a bunch of data
stores um
and it's a bunch of blue glue code
there's not much more than that
um when we started in 2010 there were
about two open source
um sort of time series database around
there was
graphite and um open to db
so graphite has it's hard to scale
graphite definitely not
to the scale that we're at it'd be
pretty hard
um and then opencv open tsb it's uh
hbase
based so uh back then we're like well
hbase i don't really want to
spend too much time uh you know dealing
with it so
we ended up building something on top of
cassandra since there's been a few
interesting pro open source projects
sometimes series databases
um influx db um
vena from ghost circuit so there's a
number of them that are that are out
there
they tend to be based on like level db
for storage and things like that so if
you're interested
um i can definitely uh get into details
but that's that's really what the data
layer is is it's not very complicated
it's just uh just a bunch of
ways so the tools we used for that is um
so redis is as you can guess all the
stuff that's in memory is in redis
it's nice because we used it to because
it gives you very
regular access to your data so if you
have time series kind of flow naturally
in redis
we use so that's the low durability
super fast access you have cassandra
is somewhere in the middle where it's
it's much more durable and cassandra i
don't know if you guys
use it or know it's a distributed kind
of key value store let's play it that
way
so it's relatively simple to operate um
it'll store data
on disk and it's really good at writing
at cons
relatively constant speed in constant
time so you can write a lot of data and
it's not going to
degrade too much reading is a different
story
but when you're ingesting a ton of data
in it actually it works pretty well and
i realized that i forgot um
one thing um the cues that we use is
kafka
so this is from linkedin um i don't know
if you guys know what it is
it's basically a curing system that is
much simpler than most queuing systems
or the ones you may be
um used to like mq series and qp and so
on
um where it's a thin queuing layer on
top of
um the jvm which is on top of basically
the
the kernel so it's really it's really
fast your file system
faster yeah exactly
um it's uh it's really fast um
and it's really good for sequential
rights and sequential reads
and what we have are it's a first and
first out sequential rights you get the
data you write it to disk
and then something's going to pick it up
to process it and it's not it's not good
at all for random reads and random
rights but that's not
the use case here zookeeper this is
zookeeper
you know which we use for coordination
across
across a lot of services elasticsearch
that's mostly used for events
whenever you say show me all the
marketing launches in the past week and
overlay them on a graph
they're going to come from elasticsearch
postgres
we use it for um
basically storing the application the
catalog you know who the users are
what the graph definition is and so on
and so forth and then the glue really is
in python itself
so um there's actually um one of my
teammates gave a
great talk at pi data i think it was 10
days ago
about how we use python so i don't know
if there are python users in the
audience
yes if you do anything
i'm sure you know that but we had great
experience with nunpai python
particularly so it's great for us python
is great because it's
product we're very productive reasonably
productive with it that's great library
support
it's everywhere every machine we use has
python already
it's unfortunately not very memory
friendly so um
which leads us to some interesting
optimization this is the
the talk you want to you want to watch
if you want to get um
get into the sort of the details i'm
happy to go into details
on the questions as well so um a few
challenges
um and i think we're getting towards the
end of the talk
um so in terms of just to give you a
sense of scale so it's about 30 billion
data points every day that we're
receiving so
it's just machines you know it's any
number of machines sending
in total uh 30 billion data points it
runs 24 7.
um one of the challenges that we had
it's hard to monitor
so we are monitoring company but it's
it's interestingly hard to monitor our
stuff so we
we do a mix of dog fooding plus using
other other tools
um but it's yeah i mean it's a i guess
it's reality of the complex um
so real-time apps these days is like the
monitoring becomes and that's why we
have the business i guess
um is non-trivial um long-term operation
um one of the challenges so i mentioned
a few times is some ever-increasing
amount of data comes in
never stops never takes a break so
that's
as you can imagine both on a technical
side but also on the operational side
that has
um it's not easy to manage memory for us
becomes the the most precious
resource um
and that's that's just um you know i
guess that's everybody is that but
uh um because latency is so important
even though it's
it's bounded at you know a few seconds
to tens of seconds
it can't be um it can't move much higher
than that so that doesn't give us a lot
of leeway
and so when we're running when we're
running out of memory somewhere
you can you can see pretty quickly in
our internal graphs you'll see stuff
piles up somewhere in the in the
pipeline stuff starts to grow or grow
it's like oh [ __ ] we gotta fix this
so the the number one game we probably
play at
datadog is on top of building a new
product
is basically chase latency bubbles so
anything that slows down
um so it's measure and the way we do it
is very simple is like
we so we have a bunch of metrics
everything is instrumented um
so we find oh there's a jump here why is
it a spike in
time it takes to render something or
time it takes to query
one of the data stores then we basically
profile the code that does that
tune it test it hotfix and so on so
forth that's so that
that's a very constant operation or
game that we play pretty much every
single day some things happen something
like
like that is happening that's just
because the system is growing growing
growing and
the interesting thing that i didn't
mention is when we started
in 2010 obviously we didn't know if we
had a business i mean that's
a startup sorry so we wanted to have
something out of the door as quickly as
possible so we started with
a very naive um
implementation uh that was based on
postgres and we knew it was naive but it
was
it took about maybe six hours to figure
out that we had to change it
um after after we started to ingest some
data and so
the architecture that i described even
at a high level is really iterative
um it's it's just basically
doing this all the time so replacing you
know replacing this replacing that we
had queuing based on
cassandra at some point which is a
terrible idea by the way but anyway we
had it
um we said okay you know if this we
gotta then we
we put kafka in and then we had uh we
when we introduced redis that was in
response to some bottleneck
um somewhere so it's really um
you know the day-to-day is a lot of that
and that's that's pretty cool
um now in general one thing that i
really like about
the stuff that i'm doing um and
monitoring in general is that you i mean
in a technical capacity if you're
engineers um
then you are our customers and that's
great because that means that
i you know we interact with you guys um
and then we want to make something
that's useful so
so that's a little the last thing i want
to say
um we are hiring and so if you want to
become a data dog and it took me a while
to understand the
joke um so if you don't know well i'll
explain because it took me at least a
month
data is like a starter guy and dogs
sleep dog anyway if you want to become
one of us
um jobs at dinnerbeast.com
and that's it that's uh that concludes
my presentation
thank you i covered maybe a lot of
material maybe too much so i'm happy to
take
questions okay i'll do row by row
go ahead do you ever have a customer
um i will repeat the question so did we
ever have a customer that doesn't have
mtp we always have a customer who
doesn't have ntp
and so what you see is there they call
you or they call you a day
on our c and say hey i can't see my
metrics and
um you look and say yeah there's nothing
and then it happens that either
their graphs are basically in the past
because the machine is sending data
thinking it's in the past or it's in the
future so we've had cases where we look
for the data and we can't see it
it turns out that the machine is not
time synchronized so it's maybe
two hours um behind or a week ahead or
we've had a problem fairly often
unfortunately
um yeah i guess
okay so the question is do we roll up so
we roll up past data and i said we roll
it up that is to say we summarize it
so that whenever you're asking for data
to graph data
for the past month we give you 200
pixels
200 data points back or 600 data points
back and
we do that because we have already
pre-computed the we already pre-computed
summaries the time summaries
um the question is we save everything so
we save the highest
resolution data which is for us down to
the second
and from a product perspective what
happens is that it's like almost science
fiction
you look at the month of data and you
zoom in and you see more more detail you
zoom in and you see more detail until
you get to the
the finance resolution but so um yes
that's
that yeah that's available yes
absolutely uh okay so we'll
see
so are we are we servicing or serving
queries are servicing queries out of
more than one data store
uh more than one data store yeah
yeah for single quote yes um and that's
simply based on the time
boundaries of the query so um for us
the past four and a half hours i think
are in memory um so if you ask for six
hours
that started six hours ago end is now
we'll still serve the last
um the the last four and a half hours
out of memory
partly because the processes down the
pipeline that are supposed to persist
the data
may not have flushed the data yet so you
go to cassandra railway store sort of
intermediate intermediary data
maybe it's not there so that's why we
stitch the data on the fly when we query
what's hard about that what's hard about
it
um mostly because i mean the main thing
is uh
in python for instance you basically you
have to use numpy
it's not particularly hard but you just
have to align you have to time align the
array
so at the boundary when you stitch it
you have to make sure that um
there's enough overlap so you don't have
a gap for instance between stuff that's
served from memory instead of so from
this
that kind of stuff um that's that's a
fairly
well understood problem for us
yeah so um
that works uh that's a great question um
i need to be able to answer it um so the
question is how we nodded about the cost
of uh operations while we double number
customers
so the in what i showed the the the raw
um the raw intake
does not necessarily is not necessarily
the vast major bulk of the expense i
mean the bulk
the bulk of the the data is actually
going to live in
in storage and so that that grows
reasonably linearly but we can we can
compress it
um the bulk of your processing scales
relatively non-linearly because you can
i mean for one thing we optimize the
code
and we do what i mentioned that we said
we're doing is that we replace
pieces as they get too slow so that's
basically the um
uh the idea um to keep a fairly high
gross margin for the business
so uh why and i also mentioned
i forgot to mention s3 um
so elasticsearch uh how do we use the
license search we
um store if you remember
events like this stuff you know where
you have like textual annotation of the
data
we use the lesson search for that
watch out for the size of the indices
that's the main thing we've had so we it
elastic search as such works great
it's like postgres it runs out of the
box and you don't have to really watch
it
until materialize that [ __ ] there's a
problem and then you didn't
you know you missed something but that's
the because you're so busy with the rest
that you know there are
the pieces um for us that are so
elastic search redis postgres these are
run almost on their own because sunrise
getting there s3
um definitely runs um runs on its own
and the thing i wanted to say about s3
is that
um because you remember that said our
data is immutable
um being past data then s3 makes a
perfect case for that because it's
you know we never need to like randomly
seek and change a little bit here and
there
all the way behind and then i'll just
circle back
uh at this point it is running on ws yes
it's like zone
distributed and so on but yeah
so yeah we use we still use a little bit
of ebs
um it's uh it's
kind of shitty um it's very it's very
bursty
i'd say in general aws um so it
it's a great way to start that's not
where we'll end but um you know that's
that's
that so ebs clearly actually i may have
had a
i blogged about it a while back but if
you read the fine print
um they give you even if you get
provision ielts which is like a reserve
stuff on address the fine prints are
fairly interesting where they'll
guarantee performance of
how fast you can read and write only
only in x percent
of the time and only if you read and
write within certain boundaries so
i mean it's hard it's definitely a hard
problem and i think they're doing a
great job but it's still
i'm not it's not as good as like yes
it's not sometimes not even as good as
ssds on my laptop so
yeah yes yes
yeah yeah yes we did
um
so i so the the truth is i don't even
know
because this um because the thing i
obsess about
and is how much data we're receiving and
so that hasn't really changed i mean
there was a dip actually there was some
dip but we couldn't see much but how
much data are we serving i don't
really care i mean i the marketing team
and i care about
the product as a series but otherwise
like i you know i wouldn't know
yeah so which you know leads to some
interesting development
for us in the near future kind of
getting partly out of progress
yeah so the question is how and
how we monitor so we the queue system we
use is kafka um it has a concept of
topics which is
places you write to um how we monitor
the writing to the queue and the reading
from the queue
um so we basically we there
we use we have workload metrics which i
mentioned the amount of work being done
so our processes are reading from the
queue to do something in this case to
roll up or to do anomaly detection and
stuff like that
so the metrics that i will watch is how
many points have you consumed for
instance
um and so that means reading a bunch of
messages from kafka
opening them up seeing how many points
they are in each message
and so on so forth so we don't have we
don't really have interestingly enough
a great sort of native kafka
instrumentation um it's we did it kind
of above
above that layer just we care about if
we
um basically if there's a drop in
throughput so
in the number of messages you're reading
assuming the messages entering the
system
is are constant and it's a drop there
then usually we'll look at so how many
messages are consuming and also
what what the machine in terms of i o is
doing and that'll basically tell us the
story
if there's a lot of more io than before
then kafka is having some issues
so so um they themselves feed metrics
into datadog and so we have also alerts
that will tell and
the other thing engineer didn't get into
that the learning engine runs kind of
you know on a on a given schedule it
like
every um right now it's every minute it
wakes up just looks at everything and
say okay everything's fine
everything's not going over then there
are things that are not fine so that
part is independent from queueing
if there's no data i'm making to it then
for instance if a
um in front of it or some things that
are feeding it are not producing
anything then they'll tell us hey you're
not producing any
you know the producers are not doing
anything so
then we could say okay is the producers
not doing anything because they crashed
and we monitor all of them at once so we
can know this guy crashed or restarted
or is it because it's something else so
that's that's usually just the starting
point
um of the investigation is oh we are
we're expecting to receive
x amount of uh data points per second we
only got
60 what's the problem how many
processors we're running
does that make sense yeah okay cool
uh actually all the way to the back and
i'll come back
yeah sure the between
here
i think we're on zero seven uh we're
deeply thinking about zero eight but uh
yeah but um and also we wanna
um i'd like to have other people tested
in production i mean beside linkedin
and not not find out that so the failure
modes of
the so the queuing system has some
replication um uh built in in the newer
versions
and the question is so we don't use that
yet i'm a little bit cautious about
what the failure modes are going to be
like because we
give some backdrop we we're also
relatively early users of cassandra and
i've kind of been there done that so i'm
you know i can wait a little bit yeah
and so let's say you lose a data center
so you have that four and a half hours
in venice
yeah you're replicating that across
so we have i mean so yeah we
replicate data so depending on the data
store we so the casanova has built in
your application s3 yes
postgres yes kafka yes with some caveats
i mean we do it manually basically
redis has it also with some caveats but
so
yeah yeah yeah we try to have everything
everywhere
um as much as possible so the question
was uh
how we survived the individual sound
edge and knock on wood i mean there's
you know that's um are you processing in
your other ones so you have like a redis
master and then you have a reply
you know across the country yeah
yeah yeah is that live or is it just in
case
so that at this point it's mostly in
case there's there's a problem so what
so that's to the 10 to 30 seconds it's
it has happened that's
you know the [ __ ] hit the fan as well
and then we need to
fail over and then we didn't automate
every single failover scenario because
it's really damn hard to
conceptualize ahead of time what's going
to crash um and so in that case like oh
damn
it's going down so what you see if if
that happens
you'll see the graphs exactly what i was
talking about
earlier um and the kind of trade-off i
don't want to make
you start seeing this and because the
data is just not it's arrived but it's
not being
read consumed and so that's when this is
like major
major crisis mode for us and we try to
keep those as
you know as singular as possible
other questions yes
uh it's typically so um i think it's 30
30-ish thousand forty thousand machines
reporting roughly
uh how many machines we need to that for
that um
we have about i don't know maybe of
various classes but we have maybe
a 100 machines at this point
yes oh so behind you
so question is how do i shard the data
or how do we share the data in cassandra
so in cassandra um i don't
so i love cassandra to write data so we
use custom rat to persist data for let's
say about a week
uh the sharding is done by so there's a
key which is
the metric name the or the the account
name
um and also the the general time frame
you're looking at
um and the way we do it is we ttl all
the
all the rows so after 15 days the data
is going to disappear from cassandra no
matter what
because otherwise we before we had that
we had a grow
ever growing cassandra cluster um
and then it becomes impossible to delete
data and and that's when we said okay
fine we'll stop that cluster
just move all the data to s3 and start a
new one that ttls um that's so that
expires data
after 15 days and that keeps also the
footprint of cassandra relatively
small otherwise by anyone so
and nssds always
yes yeah
yeah so yes so i know my detection
um so
yeah so the question is do we automate
an amount of detection uh
at this point we don't really and the
reason is um
so you have if you have using the
you're instrumenting your app fairly
consistently you have
thousands and thousands of metrics um
and
um while a lot of people want to you
know want to buy
hey i want a money deduction you'll tell
me when
whenever there's a problem somewhere in
my data you'll hurt me
um in reality right now what people are
interested is
are there they have a few key metrics in
mind and there are
these are the ones they care about these
are the ones that their bosses
care about and so on um and that's
really where they want to be alerted
the how much
false positive you will have when you
turn on like full
the anime detection and there's a number
algorithm for that
um that's that remains to be seen so we
haven't implemented it partly because
people
you know are not there yet i think so
yes
yeah so it's um it's
it's vpn yeah yeah
um i mean you know
like hdcws so there are issues sometimes
but
it's not um you know it's decent i mean
it's it's
i wouldn't yeah so yeah
so how do we manage the consistency
between the data store so we have uh
downtowns everywhere we basically
inject um known signals inside the
the pipeline and then we check
everywhere um
that that we're expecting to see that so
we don't not only check that we expected
to see them
that they're there with the right value
for instance we produce we have
i don't have it but we have a batman
series that sort of draws the top half
of batman and
bottom you know like the sign the bat
sign um so we checked that
as you're injecting the system and you
should it should appear somewhere
down the uh down the pipeline we also
check that it appears
it appears on time so that you inject
the signal and within
you know top 60 seconds you can read it
out
if not that means there's something
that's delayed in the pipeline
so um we're doing so the question is
what do we do when we
when we trade off precision for uh for
latency we do it we skip points
basically we skip for instance every
you know we'll skip 20 10 or 20 percent
of the points
so that's we don't do that normally but
um
sometimes it's it's necessary so that's
one of the
levers we have to always try to stay
there
is uh to skip it and the truth is
because um
you know again it has a fairly high
signal uh noise ratio
the trend is still there you're losing
points it's not you know it's it doesn't
really affect your
your ability to decide much less so than
if you're if you have like a blind
graphing like
you know what's going on you know does
that make sense
so we have instrumented we have
basically uh you run a command line it
starts for a given account
starts dropping every you know every
tenth
point um of what we're receiving for a
given metric or something like that
so we have we have a number of functions
to graph
performance data we so we go
so we have a histogram so we can produce
some histograms
um we can you can derive integrate
our basic arithmetic moving averages and
so on so forth so
kind of the the traditional uh time
series
operators that that you would apply um
we and we're adding more and more
time shifting counting stuff like that
so the question is do we pretty fine
metrics the answer is no you just say
here's the metric name a val is the
timestamp he's the value in that creates
a metric
see yeah
automatically yeah whatever yeah
whatever agent we
we have yeah so the so the system stuff
so if you install if you tried it out
dog
you'll say you run it on your laptop or
your server you'll get like some
metrics out of the box like anything
around or consumption
so resource consumption but you can also
produce your own metrics which usually
the more interesting stuff is you send
your metrics about your application
because like you know cpu it's
interesting but uh not
that exciting um and not actually not
that actionable actually
so we will also let you send whatever
metric you want basically as long as it
conforms to a time series
that's that's the gist of it
cool
all right thank you very much